that thing on nascar was interesting
[Music]
yeah so there you go dudes what's up
y'all
talking [ __ ] what's up
yeah take off
ah [ __ ] bro
[ __ ]
i mean you keep your helmet on yeah
mad [ __ ] come on bro i'm keeping my
[ __ ] on boom
my helmet's not coming off that
[ __ ] was dumb to take his helmet
off
say what that's possible why don't you
drive with it off then [ __ ]
because you have the potential to get
hurt yeah but you can't throw a punch
suzu
i mean it's not happening i immediately
do that [ __ ] wow that kid's young
i immediately do that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] stopped fighting too
once he got popped
no they started fighting more they like
wrestled he just took a wrestling
because i can't i can't punch a guy who
got a [ __ ] helmet on oh wow is this
often happens when in racing did you see
that i don't understand i i understood
why formula one is more popular than
escort when i looked at these cars how
is this fun oh [ __ ] like that was kind
of crazy oh
oh he's trying to kill him
no but that's because he was upset so he
got upset with the blue car number one
did yeah and then that was his
retaliation but what the number one car
did wasn't nearly as [ __ ] as that that
was way crazier yeah
so for him to be so pissed after doesn't
make any sense where you can die so from
what i gather based on youtube comment
reading is this kid ty gibbs his
grandfather owns gibbs racing is
also the old head coach of the
washington redskins so this kid is like
people think he's like a spoiled brat
like your granddad owns a team
granddad's super respected guy old head
coach and they look at you like you're
just not him and your granddad owns the
team's the only reason you're driving
and you're just kind of like a [ __ ]
that's the guy that wouldn't take his
helmet off when he fought and then he
[ __ ] him up
it's an 18 and 19 year old the two of
them
i can't i just can't believe you're
respecting dude who didn't take the
helmet off bro yeah i respect that more
so he punched him then tried to walk
away
and then punched him a couple more times
you got to take the helmet off let's
make it even it'd be like that that's
corny bro it'd be like
son that's that's respect is shooting a
fair one is respect on the streets al
you should know better yeah if we got
beef and we shoot the fair one that's
respect
oh so you respect him because he doesn't
respect him if he's giving you the
opportunity for a fair one that's a
respectful move
that's what i'm trying to say like
you know on the streets of his beef just
they're not on the streets bro say what
they're not on the streets it's
literally the street literally it's it's
a street i mean it's a course it's a
road it's a road it's on the road on the
roads it's different
on the roads of the mandem it's
different
it's different when the mandem starts
throwing punches
it's different bro yeah but did you like
my j coleman brush yeah jay coleman
jacob was do you know he's he's
continuing you bro yo j cole is copied
like he's gotta be
british accent all of a sudden he puts
out a whole [ __ ] british song yeah
yeah yeah guy was kind of dark brian
right and jason statham was copying you
yo he been cops his accent sounded just
like you son that [ __ ] he's a
dick rider too yeah
i think i could [ __ ] him up elbow to the
top of his head split his whole [ __ ] you
got a helmet you're good bro i would
wear a helmet if i thought his helmet
you got him just so it would be even
yeah
how tall is he even you gotta be wearing
full-ass football pads to have a chance
against against who jason stathams why
otherwise he'll just kick you in the
ring you know he's an actor right like
you know he this is not real i assume he
can actually fight though why because
he'd be doing all the moves literally in
the contract like of hours upon hours of
training that he gets yeah stupid idiot
he can't he don't get
actually [ __ ] you
he don't actually get hurt when he's
fighting he just got to know the moves
his choreography training he probably
gets hurt how nobody hitting him
what part of the movie does he get hit
son the paul brothers were [ __ ]
youtubers and they do a little training
and now they could [ __ ] jason state them
up facts [ __ ] out of here you don't
think the paul brothers could beat up
jason
are you crazy no no no you guys [ __ ]
nuts they're because they're he they're
way bigger jason save them alone what's
going on yeah but that's like mixed
mushrooms
movies is this like with magic
he could fight he actually has a martial
arts background what is it
what's the martial art mark mark come on
what's the martial art
we're rolling we rolling dice we're
rolling down
you don't why you act like you don't
have a laptop he's a purple belt in
brazilian jiu-jitsu boom [ __ ] em up
purple pepper stupid
purple belly that's the top belt i don't
even think you learned how to choke yet
not talking about you would think black
isn't the top no purple and jiu-jitsu is
the top this guy why because i don't
know i'm just i'm just rolling in the
dice
no it's like it's middle it's not nice
it goes white blue purple brown black
and then like what did you just say what
did you just say no i mean i said it was
the top but it's like only the third of
like
a lot of belts
yeah
it's very middle yeah that [ __ ] is the
bottom not 16 years you got to do 16
years of training to get it he was
training for 16 years
ain't no way no no it's a minimum age to
get the belt you got to be training for
this age a year and a half year and a
half that's pretty good for a year and a
half so he did a year and a half of
martial arts training you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i think he's done other fighting no he's
a diver
that's where
he was a good diver he was a really
really good guy
professional
you're going down
google it
over all the time roll the dice wow
get the [ __ ] out of here dude
that's what he used to look like with
hair
he looks better with a shaved head he
looks like yeah paula looks like the
hair
yeah
you got a body though
okay i mean dude ow good job
diving dude
yeah
paul brothers will [ __ ] him up
like if you're a diver
you're not beating nobody yet bro 100
yeah